The idea of why being moody could be
good for you,
really has to do with taking advantage
of one of the biggest strengths and
assets that women have,
which is intuition and knowing that
something is wrong,
feeling that something is wrong and then
optimally speaking up about it.
The first thing to keep in mind,
I think that's very important is that a
mood disorder,
which is a sort of a psychiatric
diagnosis.
It's not what we're talking about.
What I'm talking about is an emotion
that comes over you and last maybe 15 to
90 seconds and then if you really feel
it and allow it to pass,
it will,
um,
moods can change minute to minute.
And someone who is moody exhibits a lot
of different moods.
And what we're talking about really is
the expression of emotion,
feeling and emotion.
I'm sitting with it,
really understanding it and then
conveying it to somebody else.
This is how I feel.
So for example,
say in the days leading up to your
period where you may feel that you're
more sensitive to your environment or
that you have a thinner skin or you're
crying more easily or more sensitive to
rejection,
it's actually good to pay attention to
these sorts of things because the truth
is the rest of the month you're sort of
ceiling that over.
You're repressing it,
you're stifling it,
you're covering over,
um,
but those things are actually important.
And what's your feeling?
For instance,
perhaps you're dissatisfied,
I'm with somebody or a relationship or
something in your life,
but the rest of the month,
you know,
you're pretty easy,
breezy and accommodating.
But then those few days before your
period where you do start to be more
discerning and critical,
it's important to pay attention to that
sort of thing.
If we feel our emotions and are able to
express,
you know,
what you're doing is upsetting to me.
I think what you're doing is wrong.
Everybody benefits and hopefully
behaviors improve.
One of my concerns that I write about
and Moody bitches is that I'm worried
that because so many people now are
choosing to take psychiatric medications
and antidepressants,
antianxiety meds that they're tamping
down,
um,
how they feel and you know,
when sometimes intuition is about having
an uneasy feeling,
you know,
something is wrong and I'm a little bit
anxious and you know,
if you stop and think about how you're
feeling and you pay attention to whether
you get anxious or not,
you can really take advantage of that.
The further away we get from nature and
from what is natural for us as social
primates,
the more sick and miserable we're going
to be.
I mean,
I'm seeing this in my private practice
in psychiatry for decades now,
um,
that if someone is sort of truer to
themselves and how they feel and how
they are,
and also doing things that are more
natural for us.
I'm like moving your body,
being outside,
getting some sun.
Um,
you know,
there are very real consequences to
moving away from nature and what's
natural for us.